alright guys when you think of venture
capitalists what do you think of well
they went to Stanford
they're engineers they have big networks
what else
they were Patagonia they like
kitesurfing and they're typically old
white male well hi I'm Shruthi Gandhi I
started her adventures I went to a
no-name school I moved to this country
without any network from India and the
whole reason I started Rory adventures
was to invest in awesome founders that
that do deep you know did sorry that
give me a big applause here I need
[Applause]
please stay with me
so I invest in founders awesome
entrepreneurs who solve problems in AI
mmm and big data so I want to step back
and tell you how I did this this is my
dream come true I don't usually talk to
a lot of people I talk to a lot of
founders one on one so again I would
love your cheers once in a while I'm
shameless so let me tell you a story in
2010 I decided to start a company I was
in Chicago the company was called
Pensieve it was based on Harry Potter
we're doing what a Dumbledore picks out
his memory and puts it in a bowl called
Pensieve so Harry can look through his
past that's what my company did it
looked through your social past to help
you make better connections in the
future sounds like a good idea to me
right
we all say it's his problems and I
thought it was really important for
someone to solve this at the same time a
lot of founders were solving this
problem and they were raising a lot of
money I on the other hand with my
co-founder both of us technical couldn't
raise a penny mind you I went to a top
engineering school
for cooking at Columbia for my master's
in computer science that's where I met
my co-founder and I went to business
school at UChicago again my South Asian
community would love these degrees and
and and brands and so forth but it
wasn't relevant VC's weren't biting it
I could not raise a penny and I was
frustrated I it cut deep I took it very
personally so that is when I was
drinking one day with my friends yeah
that's what we all do when we're all
frustrated so what does drinking one do
with my friends and I said let's reverse
engineered this VC thing I'm going to
figure out what to VC's look for in
founders when they're investing in
companies well right like what's the
best way to tackle this if you can't
beat them join them
so that's what I did I went basically
worked for free for anyone who would you
know hire me and VC I did research and
you know thesis you know all the stuff I
could do to just kind of beg for a job
someone hired me and you know what I was
actually good at it early on I erased
well early on I was able to invest in
companies that were able to kind of get
acquired by Apple mcgraw-hill Samsung
and some other companies are now still
alive and raising series D and so forth
some Softbank and other big funds yeah
so I I was getting some validation there
the other thing I learned was back to my
company was DC's love investing and
creating patterns as we all know the
pattern recognition that VC's talked
about I did not fit that pattern is what
I learned and you know why because I did
not look like what they look like and
that is when I decided again drinking
with my friends
that I was gonna change and break that
pattern I'm gonna create a fund that
invests in people like me when
in 2015 arrey ventures was born and
since then I've invested in 15 companies
I'll be missing in 15 more again in the
enterprise space in a IML big data space
so if you want to raise money please
reach out to me on Twitter at a truthy
shameless as I said you learned the hard
way so that's when I decided to raise my
fund but now that's when it brings me to
this how the am I gonna do this
sorry so I had no clue and investors in
funds are not like investors in in
companies they do not want to be found
there is no database if there is a
database it's you pay a lot of money for
it I was not gonna do that I didn't have
money so that's when I said what am I
gonna do to make this work and I went
back to my roots of just going out and
reaching to as many people who could
help me and had remotely anything to do
with raising a find and you know what
when I reach out to them they gave me
their time and advice and you know what
I didn't take that lightly
I thanked them I thanked them with
knowledge Network you know
insights anything I could to really help
them out so that's when they noticed me
they believed in me they introduced me
to some of their other friends and you
know what I think that was that was the
beginning people started to know my name
I started creating a reputation this
Chartered saying that there's you know
they started believing in me because I
was believing
believing in myself isn't there a phrase
that says that the universe conspires to
those a dream so that's what happened
when I put my intent out there people
started to help me out and then early
enough a lot of people started to
express interest in investing in the
fund to take a step back I still didn't
know what I was doing and so I was
nervous and I didn't know if I should
even take them seriously so I didn't I
continued of what I knew how to do best
at the time which is go talk to more
people drink more coffee I've continued
to do that for a while until one day one
day I ran out of runway and I said you
know what I have to test this I have to
see people really are serious about what
they say so then I went to my lawyers
and I triggered an event when people who
were expressing interest in me I started
to I've kept that in lukewarm I started
to send them paperwork I said guys here
it is I'm ready to go and most of them
converted to my surprise delightful
surprise again and then not only the
convert they actually brought their
friends in that's how investing works
when someone likes you they want to talk
to their friends about it they want to
talk at cocktail parties about it and
they invested in me that is how array
ventures was born and I have to say that
I'm still in shock that I'm here today
sharing my story with all of you
hopefully it's inspiring but if I were
to give an advice to my younger self I
would say two things be determined and
don't stop dreaming thank you
[Applause]